going to begin today with charlie
dagetta in kiev a city under new
pressure this morning from russian
forces charlie good morning
good morning to you tony we're in maidan
square in the heart of the capitol a
small concert wrapped up moments ago of
course many people have already
evacuated the city some are still taking
shelter but some took advantage of the
ceasefire in order to come here and show
some support
taking advantage of a temporary break in
the fighting to flee for their lives
even if it means leaving somebody behind
it was so terrible and my parents
i left my parents in sumi
i hope i will see
another time
the city of sumi has been the focus of
some of the worst fighting from both
sides these are smoldering russian
vehicles the cities where ceasefires
have been declared all lie along the
fault line of the stalled advance where
ukrainian troops have fought russians to
a standstill and most aren't very far
from the russian border
chernoheave to the north sumi in the
northeast kharkiv to the east mariopol
in the south the cease-fire around kiev
reflects where russian forces have
advanced to the outskirts of the capital
russian troops continue their assault
elsewhere a handout video from the
russian military shows a helicopter
allegedly taking out targets in an
undisclosed location
in urban earlier this week desperate
residents took shelter from artillery
fire under a collapsed bridge
and where we found evacuees who had just
made the crossing the bummer
ola papina broke down in tears as she
described the terrifying nights of
bombardment until she and her husband
finally decided to get her 84 year old
mother suffering from alzheimer's out of
there
her son anton has seen them off to
safety so you had to leave
yes
because
we don't know while they're shooting who
to us shooting why are they hitting a
neighborhood yeah i don't no military no
targets no no
just old people
nearby a police officer bids farewell to
his son
part of the reinforcements brought in as
russian forces advance
the toddler cries uncontrollably
refusing to accept what his father has
to say
in the hard-hit city of harkiev two
little boys are fighting for their lives
his father shows a picture of
eight-year-old dima a piece of shrapnel
embedded in his skull
vova has a bullet wound in his head
after surgery the doctor asks how he's
doing
he answers i'm fine it's too early to
know whether they'll ever fully recover
a ceasefire there came too late for
those two little boys the real question
now how long will these ceasefires hold
how many people will be able to be
evacuated there is one positive note
high-level peace talks are scheduled to
take place tomorrow tony
charlie diagonal covering the human toll
now on day 14 of the fighting charlie
thank you very much